[Music]
[Music]
so I discovered a ball skate when I was
making my first RPG which was called
lady maiden light which was cancelled
back then and I remember being jealous
of them being able to work on Dungeons
and Dragons
so I remember bulbs get is a game that
gave me a big will to explore
also about as a game that showed me how
you could interact with a party and so
I'm now super excited that we get a
chance to work on polish k3 yeah it was
really felt like working on any other
project we work on internally right it
didn't really feel like we had to really
change our gears in terms of how we
think of story and how things develop I
mean I think Marone are our first
meetings getting together and just like
laying out like okay here's a map for
the ball is a gate area where do we want
to go you know and then some of the
ideas coming out of that the kind of
what the story arc might look like it
really for me I didn't really feel like
I was changing how I did things it was
just pure story collaboration it's when
you when you look at how we approach
your games we send you in an adventure
and we give you lots of systems I would
wish you have to overcome the challenges
that are thrown at you and it's
literally what you do in your campaigns
yeah that was part of it that it was
very very easy to do align ourselves I
try not to think of of the pressure and
the fact that people have been waiting
for it for so long I have to say that
now with the announcement I'm super
nervous like I didn't expect to be this
nervous I thought I was
jaded already like I can I can handle
everything but apparently not but we're
just trying to make a really fun video
game and we think we have a really good
grasp and to the ultimate goal is
literally to make a game that we want to
play so we will see what's going to come
out of it I mean we have a really good
team working on it and these guys have
been super supportive yeah I think I'm
getting kind of a better end of the
bargain right now I just get to see the
world of the Uni come to life in a way
that we haven't really seen in a very
long time like bothers gate being fully
realized so I get to Vil almost feel
like a player again if you play one of
my campaigns at some point the dungeon
master gonna say
what will you do now and in when it
comes to go computer and video games
it's always going to be what can I do
what is are the limits of the system and
so a very big push inside line right now
as to how can we give players as much
options as possible that they have this
feeling that it is what will you do and
they come they think of it and they can
actually do it and so we had a long chat
about what the vision would be for for
for Baldur's Gate 3 and why we were a
good candidate to make it but it didn't
materialize immediately it took some
time and then as we were working our
original sin to Natan called us and he
said well do you still want to do this
yeah of course and so like this way it
started and we before I knew it I was
sitting together with Mike in one room
together with my writers and his riders
and we were talking story yeah I was
like making campaign exactly we went
where obviously you can see that in a
trailer
we're upping the production values
tremendously and this is going to be
your biggest game that we've ever made
we've never had a team so large as the
one that we have now working on one game
which is a little bit intimidating also
but I did the ultimate goal is to make
this the game that it deserves to be and
I don't know what my competitors are
doing probably I'll find out here at e3
I think that what we're making I I stand
behind very strongly and so does the
entire team so and I think that when
people will see it they will be
surprised what we're showing and trailer
you see there's a different visual
identity then if you were to look at
divinity original sin for instance when
it comes to upping the production values
what I mean by that is other than
obviously it has to look beautiful it
has to move beautifully the effects have
to be I have to have to be spectacular
it's also giving you much more depth in
the gameplay options that are available
so that that that idea of being in a
game session that is being ran by a
competent dungeon master is really
present as you play the game and so
that's I think that is really the key
driver through the entire development
Dungeons & Dragons fifth edition is
essentially a modern version of a
tabletop RPG so the
the things that they put in there we are
trying to bring to the video game so
there are some really clever systems
present in there and we are reporting
the ideas behind those inside of Polish
gate tree in terms of bring it to a
modern audience tabletop gaming is
essentially about using your creativity
with the systems that are presented to
you so what we're doing is giving you an
easy way to access those systems and
then letting you fool around and then
have the game react to that in a way
that you didn't expect so that when
you're playing it you get the feeling
like can I do this that worked I can
actually do this and you get all excited
about it as you're playing it and then
something that we try to do with the
original sin too but we're pushing much
further now with the Whitby g3 yeah and
I think that process is such at the root
of Dungeons & Dragons you know whether
you're playing a video game a computer
game or playing in the tabletop it's
that sense of discovery
you know that hope it ended nature of it
you know and I think that's why the
collaborations worked so well we have
such similar design goals I mean II it's
certainly the idea that the game is your
Dungeon Master and it comes up with a
really logical response to whatever
shenanigans that you are doing inside of
the world and whatever it is so and once
you start discovering that you get very
rapidly invested in the game world and
that's that's literally what we're
looking after what was fun for me from
my standpoint as creative director is
you're sort of setting the table but
you're not really making the meal you're
letting other people come in and pick
out what is it that they want to use and
it's been really fun seeing that
evolution you know as you've been
working on the storyline and approaching
mechanics you know I mentioned earlier I
like the feeling of being a fan again
you know right just see someone working
and obviously this is a collaborative
aspect but at one point at some point
you we you know obviously in our
creative relationship like we were set
and then you're going off and executing
and we're just getting updates back and
it's really like I think I'm as excited
as any other play that's right like it
just because it just feels so cool to
see DeeDee coming to life but then see
other creators coming in and making
their mark on it you know that's I think
what's so exciting to you about deity
because it parallels so well with what
D&E is to so many people it's their
creative outlet you know I think it's
important for us to preserve that across
our platform
whether it is you're at the tabletop
making your own campaign or you're
playing someone's vision of what DD can
be so the slogan of the game is gather
your party and because that was very
much the thing about bulge get one and
also definitely about abolish gate two
so as an original sin - we want you to
be able to play either in single-player
and multiplayer I want you to be able to
have if you're playing in multiplayer a
heroic role that there's a heroic row
for every single person within the party
and but each with their own problems
each with their own ambitions also their
own quest lines pretty much what we did
with the origin stories back in the
original sin - but with a much much
bigger focus on the party because the
party was really central to the previous
ball - skates so that is a that's a big
differentiator versus what we were doing
in original sin - and I think we've
we've come up with pretty exciting
mechanics that at some point we will
share with the world
so that is a it's a big thing the other
thing is that since we're giving support
for stay also it's going to be possible
to just send the link to somebody and
then just jump into the game and that's
a big thing because we make games that
take a long time to play it can take
over a hundred hours to play campaigns
and if you've played the originals in -
for instance and multiplayer any other
campaign somebody who was away from you
it could have taken a year by the time
you finish your campaign and so maybe
with stadia integration the fact that
you can play anywhere people will be
able to hop on easier and hotel room and
somebody else's on their laptop you
should be able to play so I'm very
excited to see what happens with that
the DD was a very long time when I
worked on I've been working on D&D for
like for 14 years now and I used to
always run into people who would tell me
when I told them my job they would
always say oh I always wanted to play
D&D but I never really had a chance or
it seemed intimidating and now basically
the same type of person I'm meeting and
they're actually playing D&D and that to
me is like the most it's a wonderful
feeling you know being almost a lifetime
fan of the game I started to laugh I
think I was first exposed to when I was
like 6 years old and it even at that age
captivated me I think the most exciting
thing about it is seeing
worlds that are really for a long time
existed for me like just in my mind you
know what for the table playing you're
describing things or if I'm at work you
know and you're hunched over word
processor writing and now they see them
really come to life in a new way and I
am one of those in my job I write you
know I'm a prime a creature words but my
favorite part of my job is when we have
a concept art push and I start seeing
like the first pass and art for a
monster or location this is like that
multiplied by multiplied by ten because
it's not just a static image it's and
it's it's not just a moving image but
thinking that this is the world now I
can enter a part of this world I've been
working on for almost 15 years and I get
to wander around and mess with it like
it's so exciting to me you know because
to me it just feels like it's a natural
evolution of Dungeons and Dragons yeah I
was one of those players who played the
heck out of the old gold box games and
baldur's gate and when it came out I
probably spent more time more hours at a
computer playing D&D than at a table
table so for for me and it's a multitude
of things I mean like I've been making
RPGs for some time and Dungeons and
Dragons has always been a go-to to get
inspiration because they've been doing
it for a very long time so in the matter
of fact my second fantasy series that
I've ever read was dragon lands the
first one was Lord of the Rings so the
chance of visualizing this and fooling
around and using all of those systems
and some of the favorite systems that
are in there in a video game is
something very cool and then the other
thing is this is Baba's gate three
people have been waiting for it for a
very very very long time so it's a big
challenge for my team and so I have a
very talented team so I'm very curious
to see how far they're gonna push it
because they're they are very big
dungeon dragons players I think we have
sessions going on pretty much all the
time
so I'm very curious to see how far
they're going to take it because the so
I'm the director on it so I come up with
an idea says this is what we're gonna do
by the week after that id has already
transformed into something much bigger
and so what the end game is going to be
well
we'll have to find that I think it's
gonna be good
[Music]